Look at this map of China and tell me if,
from what we’ve learned so far, you can
tell me about the Chinese civilization. Yep,
rivers, big ones… and from them ran the
bureaucracy and technology necessary for controlling
water.
Like Egypt, Sumer, and Mesoamerica, ancient
China represents a hydraulic civilization—one
that maintained its population by diverting
rivers to aid in irrigation—and one that
developed writing thousands of years ago.
In fact, there is an unbroken Chinese literary
and scientific tradition from this time on—not
true of Egypt, Sumer, or Mesoamerica.
And from writing, Chinese scholars naturally
developed a critical invention in knowledge
transmission and state control: you know it,
you probably hate it, the standardized test.
Today, we’re going to focus on the time
of the Northern and Southern Song Dynasties,
a time of great technical innovation. But,
before we get to the Song, let’s take a
tour through the ages and explore key elements
of Chinese scientific culture.
[Intro Music Plays]
From the beginning, science in China was a
product of the state. The very first Chinese
dynasty, the Xia, supported astronomical
research to create more accurate calendars.
Later, between 400 and 0 BCE, Chinese scholars
measured the length of the solar year to 365.25
days, predicted eclipses, recorded supernovas
and sunspots, founded a Bureau of Astronomy,
and even determined the 26,000-year cycle
of the precession of equinoxes!
Alongside this research, Chinese culture developed
a grand model of the cosmos: in an infinite,
empty space—enclosed by the great celestial
sphere—celestial bodies float around, directed
by a h“hard wind.”
This mysterious force explained how the stars
and planets moved around.
The earth sits, still, at the center of the
system. On the earth, in a zone between the
four points of the compass, stretches the
Middle Kingdom—China. The cosmos revolved
around not just earth, but China itself.
And in the symbolic center of China stands
the Son of Heaven—the emperor.
The ancient Chinese states, like others governing
large populations, developed complex ideas
about human society.
The most prominent early Chinese thinker was
Confucius, whose philosophy emphasized the
importance of tradition, etiquette, respect
for elders, and for the patriarchy.
Confucianism’s focus on an orderly human
world conflicted both with Buddhism’s transcendental
orientation toward a reality beyond this one,
and the proto-scientism of Mohism
and Legalism, which were contemporary schools
of thought that privileged rational laws.
Despite competition from these other schools,
Confucianism influenced a lot of later thought.
The official state ideology of the Song was
neo-Confucianism.
China was first unified in 221 BCE, in the
Qin Dynasty. But it was the succeeding
Han Dynasty that instituted an imperial university
and the state examinations, also called the
civil service or imperial examinations.
The state exams, which were open only to men,
were a way of ensuring that the central administration
had enough trained civil servants to oversee
the collection of taxes and building of roads,
maintain a large standing army, and roll out
agricultural reforms.
For the examinees, it also meant a chance
to jump from a lower class to a higher one.
Passage of even the first level of exams led
to exemption from corvée labor,
which was part-time unpaid work for the state.
Science, however, did not figure much into
these state examinations. The exams mostly
tested memorization and recitation from the
important government and Confucian texts.
These shaped the values of the country: examinees
were well-rounded and shared a common culture
focused on law and order.
So while the Chinese state did support research,
especially on topics such as agriculture,
meteorology, and astrology, and while there
was a large state system for educating people
and getting things done, these two threads
never quite entwined as they did at the Museum
of Alexandria or the House of Wisdom in Baghdad.
This brings us to the Song Dynasties.
The Song state produced a lot of infrastructural
and social change across China, starting with
the key to everyone’s heart, their stomachs.
During the eighth century, rice cultivation
took off in southern China and the Yangzi
Basin.
Then, in 1012, the Song state introduced new
early-ripening and winter-ripening rice from
the Champa kingdom in what is now Vietnam
that allowed rice to be produced faster with
less water
The Song state reclaimed ricefield plow and
paddle chain water-lifting devices.
These agricultural changes led to the growth
of a leisured middle class, increased trade,
and a growth in manufacturing.
Within a century, urbanization skyrocketed:
urban population reached twenty percent of
the total even as population jumped from fifty
million to one hundred and fifteen million.
And we moderns know what hegemonic powers
want, right?
A gigantic state bureaucracy!
In medieval China’s case, this meant the
highly centralized mandarinate, a term referencing
Mandarin, the dialect of Chinese employed
in the imperial court.
The bureaucrats who oversaw the imperial exams
became known as “mandarins.” The mandarinate
provided social stability and, thanks to the
exams, some insulation against corruption.
Systematic knowledge production in abstract
natural philosophy was never unified. But
Chinese technē was another story.
Whereas scholars had high status, craftspeople
had low status. The state controlled most
industries, and the state was responsible
for programmatic improvements.
The list of Chinese “firsts” or true technical
inventions is so long that it could be its
own episode.
The wheelbarrow, silk production, earthquake
monitors, lacquer, gunpowder, the crossbow,
porcelain, umbrellas, fishing reels, suspension
bridges, and paper money.
As fascinating as this list is, it’s of
somewhat limited analytic value, because it
doesn’t tell us anything about the social
and political context of technological invention.
What are the characteristics of a given society
that lead to new ideas? Does the state help
or hinder this work? Let’s look at some
examples.
Sometimes a practical invention led to new
scientific knowledge after the fact. For example,
the Chinese had tinkered with magnetic compasses
since 300 BCE, but the concept of attraction
to the North Pole was not understood for another
two hundred years.
Other times, cultural desires drive lots of
little iterations that lead to major breakthroughs.
For instance, Chinese artisans made paper
since the second century CE, although it may
have been developed even earlier.
And by 700, the Chinese also made use of a
printing press involving carved wood blocks.
In fact, the first Song emperor ordered the
printing of a compilation of Buddhist scripture
that included 130,000 two-page wood blocks
in 5048 volumes!
But printing really took off in 1040, when
Song artisans introduced the first movable-type
printing presses using wood and, later, ceramic
characters. These helped standardize writing
and unify Song culture.
Finally, sometimes the state would directly
support the creation of new knowledge.
Sponsored by the state, Chinese artisans created
complex astronomical clocks and orreries,
or mechanical models of the heavens.
During the Song Dynasty, civil servant Su
Song refined these techniques to construct
a gigantic machine that would replicate planetary
movements and allow the government to correct
the official calendar.
Alchemy—or a systematic investigation of
“what is stuff?”—also took off with
state support, starting in the Han dynasty.
Thanks to this work, the Chinese had gunpowder
as of the mid-ninth century. But it took until
roughly the twelfth century, under the Song,
to perfect the military application of such
a volatile substance.
But as fascinating as medieval gunsmithing
is, the real achievements of Chinese technology
were in infrastructure.
This includes everything from taking raw ore
and making it into usable iron, to moving
vast quantities of water around.
Medieval China saw an infrastructure revolution.
Show us what it looked like, Thought Bubble!
Iron production in China had been a state
enterprise since 117 BCE. But under the Song,
iron production skyrocketed, increasing by
sixfold from CE 800 to 1100. In 1078, for
example, the Song state foundries produced
125,000 tons of iron!
How did they do it? Knowing more about the
chemical properties of stuff! Specifically:
coal.
By the late Song, households used coal for
heating, which was much more efficient than
charcoal. Coal burns hotter, for longer, and
doesn’t require deforesting the lands around
cities.
This allowed iron production to scale up without
destabilizing society. And iron workers used
water-powered bellows by the eleventh century,
smelting ore with coke—a powerful fuel made
from coal which burns hot and clean.
The Song state made 32,000 suits of armor,
16 million arrowheads, not to mention loads
of agricultural implements, every year!
In addition to metallurgy-backed military
might, hydraulic engineering is vital in running
large states. But the Grand Canal took infrastructure
into a new scale.
Completed in 1327, the Grand Canal stretched
eleven hundred miles, from Hangzhou in the south up to Beijing in the north.
This is about the distance from New York to
Florida. The Grand Canal allowed merchants
to ship up to four hundred thousand tons of
grain every year.
The Great Wall is pretty wondrous, as far
as long-term engineering projects go, but
the Grand Canal was not only a technical project—necessitating
the water-level-adjusting pound lock (a technology
we still use in canals to this day) —but
a social and economic one.
Thanks, Thought Bubble! The efficient moving-around
of goods is characteristic of the Chinese
world by the time of the Song—when economic
activity and population boomed alongside the
ability to grow more rice.
The Canal also represented the powerful Chinese
state’s ability to engineer vast regions:
they connected smaller waterways to main rivers,
opening up where goods and people could travel.
But—as political winds shifted—certain
sections were expanded or left to silt in.
So centuries later, during the Ming Dynasty,
the Grand Canal had to be massively restored.
The Ming repaired 40,987 reservoirs and planted
a billion trees. Billion… With a B.
The story of natural philosophy in China is
similar to the story in other early states:
useful science was prioritized, not science
for its own sake.
Given its resources, state support of research,
population, and impressive track record regarding
technical innovation, some historians have
asked why a “Scientific Revolution” didn’t
occur during Song Dynasty China.
But is this question useful in helping us
make sense of past systems of knowledge-making?
For one, many revolutionary technical achievements
in medieval China were made over long periods
of time by anonymous, lower-class artisans,
not individual, named scholars.
Two, in another sense, a “Scientific Revolution”
did happen!
Coal, water-powered bellows, gunpowder, compass-assisted
navigation, centuries-long hydraulic engineering
schemes, movable-type presses, massive urbanization,
and research-driven agricultural intensification—added
up, these sound pretty revolutionary! And
many of these inventions traveled well beyond
China.
But! The Song state fell to—wait for it—the
Mongols…
….so these achievements didn’t all persist
in time. The more important point is that
changes in how cultures have understood and
manipulated the natural world don’t follow
a single predictable model.
Chinese historians have seriously challenged
the assumption that a so-called “Scientific
Revolution” is a necessary path for all
civilizations.
Next time—we’ll zoom in on the field of
medicine and compare systems of making knowledge
about health across Eurasia and north Africa.
Crash Course History of Science is filmed
in the Dr. Cheryl C. Kinney studio in Missoula,
Montana and it’s made with the help of all
this nice people and our animation team is
Thought Cafe.
Crash Course is a Complexly production. If
you wanna keep imagining the world complexly
with us, you can check out some of our other
channels like Nature League, Animal Wonders,
and Scishow Space.
And, if you’d like to keep Crash Course
free for everybody, forever, you can support
the series at Patreon; a crowdfunding platform
that allows you to support the content you
love. Thank you to all of our patrons for
making Crash Course possible with their continued
support.